[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de pas
fou dans lequel nous allons parler
beaucoup de la loi qui est actuellement
discuté à l'assemblée qui la loi sur le
séparatisme ou la loi renforçant les
principes de la république et on va
poser la question les religions hôtel
raison de s'inquiéter de 7,3 et puis
nous allons parler évidemment de
l'actualité avec les menaces dont a été
l'objet un professeur de philosophie à
trappes pour avoir soutenu
samuel pâtit alors pour parler de tous
ces sujets je suis ravi d'accueillir mon
seigneur bruno valentin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes d'évêque auxiliaire de
versailles
et justement ça va être très intéressant
d'avoir la position des catholiques sur
sept sur sept mois jean charles lajoie
ni bonjour bonjour vous êtes éditeur
toujours et puis nous avons évidemment
parce que la loi pose des problèmes
juridiques importants donc deux juristes
éminents c'était fatma son bonjour bon
jean patrice êtes professeur à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et doyen honoraire de la faculté de
droit et vincent couronne bonjour
bonjour vous êtes enseignant aussi un
lieu des excuses et et fondateur des
surligneurs alors on va commencer quand
même par cet événement d'actualité
c'est à dire ce professeur menacée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est un professeur de philosophie
d'indicés de trappes qui est donc qui
reçu donc des menaces de mort depuis
qu'il a publié une lettre ouverte
adressée aux enseignants dans
l'observateur lettre dans laquelle il
prône notamment la défense de samuel
pâtissent interrogé sur sur le le rôle
des enseignants
dans ces circonstances la première je
vous conseille pas vous c'est la
première réaction alors à l'écouté ces
dernières heures je n'ai pas bien perçu
qu'il est effectivement reçu des menaces
explicites
je crois avoir compris que c'est plus un
climat qui le préoccupe mais bon ça
change pas fondamentalement les choses
fondamentalement ma première réaction
c'est que il ya là une fois de plus si
je puis dire un double enjeu qui est un
enjeu immédiat de sécurité mais qui est
aussi un enjeu plus fondamental de
vérité sur le plan de la sécurité
il semble que le préfet la rectrice
d'académie et pris les choses très au
sérieux et se soit mobilisée comme il le
faut je crois que c'est aussi au nom de
la sécurité qu'il faut se garder de tout
propos excessifs
un certain nombre d'aidés des
commentaires et même des formules de
monsieur le maire lui-même ces dernières
heures m'inquiète m'inquiète parce que
écrire comme il l'a fait dans le point
que trame de mer s'est-t-il ville perdue
oui c'est un peu écrit peut tromper une
ville perdue c'est pas possible
alors va y revenir parce que vous m'avez
communiqué martigues est absolument
passionnant qui est paru dans vatican
news sur la ville de trappes
c'est vrai qu'on en reparle tolèrent
parce que c'est une vision assez
nouvelle qu'on peut avoir de la ville de
trappes mais vous l'avez la première
action que vous voulez c'est sûr c'est
sur ces menaces jean-charles de jeu ni
même moi je suis effondré par le silence
qui entoure tout ça j'ai entendu ce
matin de 7h à 9h
une grande antenne nationale de radio il
ya eu à peine une demi seconde consacré
à ça on nous parle de tas de choses qui
ont un intérêt tout à fait relatif mais
ça on a l'impression que les médias que
les ans les hommes politiques la
totalité du personnel important si je
puis dire et terrorisés se dit oulala
idée menacé c'est pas le moment alors
c'est magique c'est ce que les gens se
disent c'est pas le moment de prendre la
parole c'est pas le moment de dire que
c'est bien que c'est mal c'est ne disant
rien on remet un couvercle sur la
marmite et puis voilà quand ça explosera
on espère de culte la voilà c'est
surtout très vague mais certains cas une
trouille et que c'est déprimant parce
que c'est à l'invers de tout ce qu'il
faudrait faire évidemment je dis il faut
être intraitable avec ce genre de ce
genre de choses comme le dit tout à fait
justement monseigneur on quelle que soit
la nature des menaces et quelle que soit
l'heure la réalité c'est une ambiance et
un climat qui est tout à fait tout à
fait des vagues
il devrait y avoir un front commun et
tous les hommes politiques de gauche à
droite devraient se militer contre ça et
soutenir ce soutien ans cet enseignant
et soutenir les enseignants et soutenir
les gens qui ont une parole libre encore
une fois on peut débattre de tout mais
il faut qu'on puisse tout dire voilà ça
c'est inquiétant
c'était fade montceau oui moi je juge
vous écouté avec intérêt j'ai lu aussi
avec grand intérêt à ce que le père
valentin à nous à nous a diffusé ce
matin
moi je ferai la distinction probablement
entre entre ce qui se passe dans le
milieu scolaire spécifiquement collège
et au lycée et on se doute que enseigné
au lycée de la plaine de neauphle non
seulement la philosophie mais aussi
l'histoire où une certaine partie des
sciences d'ailleurs ça doit pas toujours
être très aisé très facile mais je
distingue de ce qui peut se passer au
sein donc de ce service public de
l'enseignement et de ce que de ce qui
peut se passer dans la dans la ville moi
j'ai aussi sans doute un regard un peu
plus optimiste sur ce qui peut se
dérouler dans la ville dans les
quartiers de trappes
alors tant du côté des communautés
religieuses qui je le vois d'assez loin
mais qui me semble en effet dans un
dialogue assez constructif que du côté
d'initiative d'initiative citoyenne mon
cher patrice évidemment nous savons par
exemple la contribution que quelqu'un
comme moustapha larbaoui peux te peut
apporter à cette à cette pacification
donc je rejoins jean charles lorsqu ils
s'inquiètent
j'espère que la réaction que les
réactions du service des services
académiques sera à la hauteur
c'est à dire qu'on ne se contentera pas
de mettre un mouchoir sur cette question
en essayant d'oublier très vite mais je
souscris aussi haut à l'analyse du père
valentin alors qu'il connaît bien trappe
au demeurant dans son dans son optimisme
vincent couronne mais moi je je je je
suis assez d'accord avec avec
jean-charles camp sidy qu'effectivement
les médias on parle assez peu mais en
même temps je me dis que à quoi bon en
fait tant parler dans les médias
à quoi bon en fait faire un bras en me
rendant branle-bas-de-combat pardon pour
pour cette affaire là qu'ils auraient en
fait pour effet de terroriser encore
plus la communauté enseignante
je pense qu'il ya un équilibre à trouver
entre cd en fait aux as que comment dire
le certains le prédicateur où certains
discours etc veulent en fait de nous
faire donner comme impression et la
réalité des choses et donc sur le
terrain moi en tout cas c'est bon c'est
mon impression est mon observation de
mon modeste positionnement j'ai
l'impression quand même que dans les
salles de cours la liberté d'expression
quand même un petit peu reculer et donc
on peut se demander est ce que c'est
vraiment justifiée ou pas est ce que est
ce qu'on n'est pas tous individuellement
un petit peu effectivement terroriser et
c'est donc alors que moi par exemple un
cadre particulier je n'ai jamais eu
aucun problème
de contestation de ce que je disais de
mes propos quoique ce soit que ce soit
dans les salles de cours ou à
l'extérieur
donc je ne sais pas trop en fait si
vraiment il faut vraiment faut plus
médiatisé ça et puis comme le disait
stéphane aussi il ya une nécessité de
réaction en revanche la part de
l'administration
le ca pour le coup oui alors une
médiatisation peut être pas mais une
réaction ferme de la part de deux des
services compétents ça ça c'est certain
alors on va évidemment c'est de survivre
dans l'est dans les heures qui viennent
et le le journal de tv 68 voix fait un
grand événement sur cette affaire mais
je voudrais qu'on revienne justement
alors il ya ce creuset qui est trappe
autour de cette affaire et avec une
délégation trappe vous avez rencontré le
pape françois et en est donc ce cet
article la paroisse de trappes creuset
d'une fraternité concrètes et décapante
alors quelle est la situation s'étant
défait de le père etienne guillet qui
est près du dossier du diocèse de
versailles est prête à trappes qui
raconte au fond son vécu de la ville de
trappes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qu'est ce qu'ils cet article justement
et la réalité telle que la vie le prêtre
de trappes
oui straps et 30000 habitants et donc
3000 habitants ne peuvent pas être
enfermé dans une réalité sociologique
unique évidemment attrape il y à une
paroisse catholique dynamique vivante
qui est ni plus ni moins que composaient
des habitants de trappes donc avec les
mêmes questions sociales les mêmes
questions de pauvreté la même
composition de populations étrangères et
à paris de cette paroisse qui est
caractérisée par un vrai dynamisme tout
un chacun peut se rendre compte en y
allant le dimanche à la messe se joue et
se réalise de vraies expériences de
dialogue très au delà des murs tirer
c'est pas une paroisse qui se soucie
uniquement d'aylmer paroisse qui est
engagée aussi bien sur le front des
questions de pauvreté par exemple en
animant des ateliers pour les enfants
qui sont au pavillon bleu
l'hôtel social bornes nationale que en
prenant des initiatives de dialogue avec
la grande mosquée avec les les
principales qualités musulmane de la
ville donc ce qui intéressait le vatican
dans cette réalité de trappes
c'est une expérience objectivement
prometteuse de dialogue parce que
derrière le pape françois cau 17 trappe
oui alors quand on l'a rencontré il ya
un an pile on est ce qu a permis
d'ailleurs que ce voyage se fasse et
c'est vrai que tout de suite s'est noué
avec lui un dialogue assez directe où il
a interrogé les trappistes qui étaient
là sur leurs relations avec l'islam sur
la façon dont se déroulait la vie
quotidienne dans ce contexte ce qui nous
a montré un intérêt assez pointu
qu'est-ce qui a confirmé cet intérêt
c'est que j'ai appris que ce fameux
article a été traduit en arabe pour être
transféré à l'université al-azhar au
caire qui est le haut lieu de l'islam
sunnite
pour le monde entier et ça c'est le
vatican quatre ans puis cet article
pourquoi cette anecdote m'intéresse
parce qu'elle montre que travailler est
un point d'attention international pas
seulement pour le pire mais aussi pour
le meilleur
alors juste parce qu est ce qui est
assez intéressant dans ce dans cet
article c'est alors il d'abord il ya les
chiffres je crois qu'elle est l'église
c'est 400 personnes exerçant le musc et
3000 à peu près rien n'est pas question
de nier l'évidence à savoir
qu'aujourd'hui dans une ville comme
trappe l'islam est majoritaire bien sûr
mais il ya une fine une collaboration
entre les entre les religions peut-être
entre les responsables des religions et
il ya surtout si vous voulez une façon
de penser la vie ensemble qui ne
coïncide pas avec les limites religieuse
parce que
l'église catholique a trap c'est aussi
l'école sainte-marie bon l'école sainte
marie c'est 70 % d'enfants musulmans
la paroisse catholique de trappes c'est
aussi un service de soutien scolaire qui
accueille toutes les semaines sans
enfant sur ces 100 enfants vous avez une
bonne part d'enfants musulmans
noyer il fait pas il faut pas entrer
dans un réseau communautariste
voilà à dire il faut pas considérer que
à part dons au parti on appartient à une
communauté religieuse
on vit dans cette communauté et on ne
sert que les intérêts de cette
communauté
la paroisse de trappes et la
démonstration inverse stéphane manceau
vous avez vous évaluez cet article
oui oui oui comme je le signalais j'ai
lu avec beaucoup d'intérêt
et évidemment on voit enfin une
situation qui qui qui est particulier à
saillir situation d'une commune dans
laquelle une commune relativement
importante 30000 habitants dans laquelle
les adeptes de de confession catholique
sont minoritaires et sont très
minoritaires
donc on voit au fond que les choses
peuvent peuvent fort bien se passer
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya on sait on
sait que la ville de trappes à fourche
la vie de la trappe non mais que son
parti de trappes un nombre très
important si on le ramène au nombre
d'habitants un nombre très important de
deux jeunes en syrie les services de
renseignement les services policiers
français parlait d'ailleurs à cette
époque du traspy ce temps et ça c'est
aussi une réalité est une réalité il ya
un noyau dur d'un intégrisme islamique
qui est qui et qui est aussi hélas une
réalité et qui est parfois été favorisée
par des décisions politiques politique
d'ailleurs c'est le musulman
le livre de deux journalistes du monde
justement c'est ce qui est intéressant
mais s'il en était besoin est
intéressant dans dans cet article est et
qui est si on le met en perspective avec
la sphère de ce professeur de monsieur
le maire c'est qu'au fond il ya deux
visions
assez opposées qu'on peut faire d'une
ville comme trappe une vison un peu
pessimiste du genre la partie est déjà
perdue et une vision peut-être plus
optimiste que celle des croyants
peut-être qui est de dire dont il ya des
choses à faire il ya bien creuser qu'on
peut sur lequel on peut travailler enfin
normal et dit bien heureux que
monseigneur excès par exemple soit fasse
preuve d'un peu d'optimisme parce que si
les optimistes ne vient pas de la
douleur at il effectivement on peut
faire des constats on a tous fait
stéphane minson viens de me faire il ya
les deux choses en tant qu'éditeur on
voit bien il ya quasiment la seule
librairie de quasiment deux trappes on
voit et il y allume un hidjab en en
vitrine enfin je veux dire c'est bon
c'est totalement déprimant comme cocoon
comme vision culturelle et de delachaux
seconde phase est absolument à des liens
après qu'il m'eut heures d'espoir juif
je me demande qui avoue croire mais
voilà cdl et les faibles arbre quand on
l'a vu quand on voit ça comme ça donc
mais je ne travaille pas su rattraper
voit la chose une au cinéma longtemps
l'important c'est que cet espace ne
soient pas des mots voilà l'importance
et qui se traduit par des engagements
des réalisations concrètement et à cet
égard des choses se vivent à trappes
c'est pour ça que moi je connais bien
cette ville pour y avoir été moi même
prêtre et j'ai commencé à trappes comme
monsieur le maire en l'an 2000 donc je
connaisse être cette ville et je sais
depuis de manière très tenace la volonté
de beaucoup de gens de tous horizons de
faire des choses attrape moi un des
soutiens les plus forts que je garde de
mon travail de prêtres à trappes
c'est précisément la ténacité et
l'engagement des enseignants des écoles
des collèges et du lycée public voilà
d'aider des hommes et des femmes parce
que j'ai pas mal dialoguer avec la
prédécesseure is de monsieur le maire la
professeur de philo de l'époque où j'y
étais qui était une figure de la
militance laïque athée et avec les qu'on
avait il ya eu de vrais dialogues parce
que parce qu'encore une fois beaucoup de
gens s'engagent pour faire avancer les
choses et c'est ça qui constitue la
possibilité d'espérer et le possibilité
d'espérer c'est probable
passe probablement par l'enseignement et
par l'éducation un café mustapha
larbaoui et je crois qu a fait un
travail tout à fait remarquable luttant
effectivement contre les dérives
islamistes et c'est le sport maintenant
le truc d'une main de fer et je crois
que c'était tout à fait positif comme un
comme action il le grenelle du sport
amateur et du facteur d'intégration qui
s'est tenu la semaine dernière à la
guerche légaux mais c'était passionnant
sur ce plan vincent couronne sur ceux
sur trappe justement sur ces deux
figures d'une ville comme ça entre la
menace et d'espoir moi j'suis nature
plutôt optimiste donc j'ai envie
d'espérer aussi de me ranger de ce côté
là après c'est un sentiment
comment dire encore une fois comme
jean-charles je ne connais pas très bien
trappe
même si des étudiants qui viennent de
travail etc
mais c'est pas j'ai pas une experte du
terrain maintenant si on me dit que il
ya ces deux faces là qui existe à
trappes
j'ai envie de prendre celle plus plus
positive et optimiste
après je trouve que cette question là et
ce débat il a il a un sens à l'égard du
projet de loi que l'on appelle encore de
lutte contre le séparatisme qui est en
ce moment en débat au parlement
parce que ça montre la place centrale de
l'éducation alors vous vous disiez du
sport également je suis tout à fait
d'accord aussi
mais outre les mesures répressives de
contrôle etc
il ya eu un travail de longue haleine
mais qui évidemment politiquement ne pas
avoir d'effet que de manière très
incertaine et sur le très long terme
mais c'est probablement là que l'effet
le plus profond et le plus utile
c'est sur les violations vincent qu'on
voit que vous venez de me faire une
disons toute trouvée puisque on va
aborder le sujet de cette loi discutée
actuellement à l'assemblée loi qu'on
appelait sur le séparatisme qui est qui
et la loi pour renforcer les principes
de la république
enfin voila on la connaît sur le nom
doit sur le séparatisme
[Musique]
alors je commence par aborder une des
questions importantes
on a vu que évidemment la loi au départ
était censé régler si je peux dire la
question de l'islam et de l'islamisme et
on voit qu'au fond les religions les
protestants les catholiques sont très
critiques sur ce sur ce projet de loi
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi c'est moi qui m'inquiète
beaucoup et qui inquiète beaucoup des
évêques de france comme évêque
catholique mais peut-être plus encore
comme citoyen parce que plus le débat
parlementaire avance et plus nous avons
le sentiment qu'elle va manquer sa cible
en nourrissant chez les croyants une
forme de séparatisme intime du fait du
message de défiance de soupçon que
quelles que soient par ailleurs les
intentions du législateur
cette loi fait passer voilà je vous en
donne un seul exemple pour voir comment
des dispositions techniques nourrissent
en réalité un climat disposition juste
un exemple pour vous dire pourquoi
la principale inquiétude vis-à-vis cette
loi c'est le climat de soupçon qu elle
insinue dans les règles de la laïcité en
france désormais le diocèse de
versailles à 220 ans ce qui est
relativement jeune pour un diocèse
catholique en france libre évidemment ça
son statut juridique a changé c'est bien
parce que nous sommes en région
parisienne et que donc l'agent
parisienne service étaient en arrêt
diocèse a été créée en 1802 bon
évidemment son statut juridique a évolué
sur 200 ans
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un statut
juridique qui a 100 ans
voilà puisqu'ils datent de des
adaptations aux catholiques de loi de
faisant face à la faim dans les années
20 est bien de par cette loi
nous allons passer désormais un statut
juridique qui aura une durée de vie de 5
ans tous les cinq ans nous devrons
revenir à la préfecture pour demander au
préfet de bien vouloir nous reconnaître
une existence légale
pourquoi les catholiques des yvelines
sont ils des gens dangereux pour que eux
qui avaient un statut en place depuis
100 ans
se voit désormais attribuer un statut
qui n'aura plus qu'une durée de vie de 5
ans alors le seul message qu'on peut
entendre c'est vous êtes des gens dont
il faut se méfier et donc tous les ans
nous réévaluerons tous les cinq ans nous
réévaluerons votre orthodoxie
républicaine c'est objectivement
vexatoire alors il ya peut-être une
explication je pense que c'est ce que va
donner
jean-charles mais qu'on peut lire aussi
dans la croix gd hurla coin d'un éditeur
et qui devait à l'origine c'était bien
une certaine conception de l'islam dans
sa version politiques étaient visés par
la loi
mais afin de ne pas stigmatiser les
musulmans dans leur ensemble projet
brasse très large à la manière de filets
dérivants certaines dispositions auront
potentiellement des conséquences sur
tous les cultes sans distinction parce
que c'est votre explication exactement
exactement on voit bien dans les médias
sur tous les plateaux de télévision dès
que quelqu'un prend la parole autour ou
à propos de l'islam ou de l'islamisme le
préambule automatique c'est de dire et
c'est la même chose pour les catholiques
c'est la même chose sur les protestants
tout de suite et on se ne plus personne
n'ose parler de l'islam ou de
l'islamisme tout il faut dire on englobe
tout toutes les religions ce qu'on
disait la dernière fois pendant
l'émission avec le
député je suis molière mais parlons plus
de vivienne meyer est qui et qui tout
petit on avait l'impression qu'il
craignait des séparatismes catholique
des séparatismes protestants gd mais
est-ce qui est ce qu'ils existent et de
cette phrase extraordinaire
non mais ça pourrait baisser on est chez
les fous on est chez les fous se dire c
est ce que quelqu'un peut me dire ce
qu'on peut craindre de la religion
catholique ou de la religion protestante
est ce que est ce qu'il ya le moindre
soupçon de deux choses tout à fait mon
seigneur je sais on est au delà du
ridicule de demander aux catholiques que
de 2,2 faire preuve de républicanisme
enfin que j'en est chez les fous je vais
passer la part le haut juriste et
professeur de droit mais je crois que
c'est le président de la fédération
protestante qui écrit ceci effectivement
il existe une menace islamiste
mais le projet de loi touche ce qui
précisément jouent le jeu de république
est-ce que escaufourt dit on est victime
de ceux qui ne jouent pas et vous on est
considéré comme ceux qui ne jouent pas
le jeu de la république mais ça me
semble évident et c'est là où je pense
que c'est pour avoir raté sa cible
c'est parce que en durcissant le cadre
des associations cultuelles on va
évidemment dissuader un peu plus ceux
qui n'y sont pas déjà de le rejoindre
pas plus tard qu'avant-hier un des
recteurs des grandes mosquées des
yvelines disait au curé de la ville avec
ce qui est en train de se préparer
nous n'irons jamais dans leur statut de
1905 puisque aujourd'hui comme beaucoup
de mosquées il son substitut 1901
c'est à dire les associations de
philatélistes de sportifs ou autres
bon et bien précisément ils disaient
mais avec ce durcissement de la loi
c'est pas demain la veille que nous on
rentrera sous ce statut là donc ce que
ce que la loi essaye de leur mais le
présentateur de bande a reçu en octobre
les grandes écoles pour présenter ses
intentions a dit précisément ça il a dit
moi mon but c'est que toute la vie
cultuelle rejoignent 1905 ce
qu'aujourd'hui elle se elles se
déploient beaucoup sous des abus divers
contrôler et on associe à une loi qui va
rendre 905 plus dissuasif donc outre
emmerder excusez moi les mots les gens
qui le menace personne j'ai la
prétention de menacer personne on
dissuade les gens qu'on voudrait
inscrire dans le cadre républicain de le
rejoindre ses fans manceau alors est-ce
qu'il faut une explication technique au
fond et dire qu'une loi ne peut pas
viser une seule religion et qu'elles
étaient visibles des visées tout même si
tout ne présentent pas les mêmes
caractéristiques
vous avez vous avez de beaux restes mon
cher patrice davost de vos études
juridiques
la situation française a ceci de
particulier
alors on pourrait sur la notion même de
laïcité y passer des heures et des jours
tant la question est complexe étant
chacun prétend avoir sa propre
définition de la notion mais la question
était complexe au point que en effet la
puissance publique ne peut pas
discriminer il n'est
constitutionnellement pas possible de
viser une institution religieuse en
particulier tout en laissant les autres
de côté alors il ya je citerai un
exemple alors kiki qui est un exemple
récurrents notamment depuis depuis que
jean pierre chevènement est passé par le
ministre de l'intérieur vous savez cette
volonté de la part de l'état d'organiser
un islam de france
voilà une situation à laquelle l'état se
heurte dans des situations d'échec on va
d'échec en échec pourquoi parce que le
le régime juridique et constitutionnel
qui s'applique aux relations entre
l'état et les institutions religieuses
ne permet pas à l'état d'intervenir pour
structurer une institution religieuse
eh bien on est à peu près dans les mêmes
contradictions dans les mêmes
difficultés pour la puissance publique
alors sur ce que disait le père valentin
à propos de des associations loi de 1905
des associations cultuelles dans
lesquelles il a raison d'ailleurs d'un
les associations diocésaines de 1924 le
il y a en effet des contraintes alors
des contraintes qui tenta dans le projet
doit en effet être à être resserré et là
je fais toujours une parenthèse on verra
ce que le constituent le conseil
constitutionnel en dira on verra aussi
ce que le conseil d'état pourra dire des
décrets d'application et de la mise en
oeuvre de ces textes est là et là je
referme la parenthèse mais sur ces
associations loi de 1905 qui ont
vraiment été conçu par la loi du 9
décembre 1905 comme étant des textes sur
mesure pour les institutions religieuses
la loi de 1901 sur les associations
avaient d'ailleurs été dès 1901 prélude
à cette évolution il faut pas oublier
non plus que ces structures associatives
emporte un certain nombre davantage pour
ceux qui qui s'y sont adhérer qui s'y
sont constitués des avantages notamment
en matière fiscale des avantages est
également nouveau que le projet de loi
va ouvrir à ces associations la 10 905
et qui consiste pour les institutions
religieuses à pouvoir tirer des revenus
de gestion de la gestion immobilière des
immeubles dont elles sont une ces
associations propriétaires et ça c'est
évidemment un avantage pécuniaire qui
probablement incitera certains à bascule
et du régime de 1900 vers celui de 1905
notamment pour les mosquées alors
notamment pour les mosquées mais
j'allais vous dire que là du côté de
l'immobilier du côté des édifices de la
construction d'édifices du culte et plus
particulièrement des mosquées on a en
france un régime qui est de ce point de
vue très libérale et qui permet
notamment via un mécanisme qui s'appelle
le bail emphytéotique
je laisse ça de côté c'est assez
technique qui permet de consentir au
fonds d aide assez importante aux
institutions religieuses pour notamment
la réalisation des mosquées et puis je
n'oublie évidemment pas non
le fait que la plupart des édifices
catholiques qui ont été réalisés avant
1905 sont aujourd'hui des propriétés
publiques ce qui implique évidemment une
obligation de la part des communes et de
l'état et de certaines institutions de
certains jeux pci de coopération
intercommunale ce qui implique une
obligation d'entretien donc ses 21 ans
est contrainte mais il ya aussi en fr
certain nombre d'avantagés conséquents
valentin voudrais vous répondre je ne
veux pas noyer ceux qui nous écoutent
des détails techniques mais je suis
quand même obligé de m'inscrire en faux
par rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit
parce que la loi sur l'économie
solidaire de 2017 à modifier
fondamentalement cette donne en
permettant à toutes les associations loi
1901 de détenir de l'immobilier
de la même manière soit reçue à titre
gratuit des héritages ils soient achetés
dans là dans une logique de placement
bon aujourd'hui à nous il est fait
interdiction d'avoir des immeubles que
nous aurions acheté dans une logique de
placement et a priori malgré nos
demandes la loi en discussion
maintiendra cette interdiction est donc
il ne nous ait concédé que la
possibilité de mettre en location les
immeubles que nous détiendrons à titre
gratuit reçu en héritage
donc contrairement à ce qui vient d'être
dit nous faisons aujourd'hui l'objet
d'une discrimination par rapport aux
autres associations dans notre liberté
de gestion de nos ressources des vins ne
voulait répondre à ça non mais si si
discrimination il ya de toute façon et
la loi est en discussion il est question
de plafonner etc
les les aspect pécuniaire mais si
discrimination il ya il faudra le faire
valoir devant les juridictions et le
conseil constitutionnel ne manquera pas
de censurer et tout comme le conseil
d'état dans les mesures d'application
vincent couronne peut-être un rappel
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de cette loi
de 1905 de loi de la séparation de
l'église et de l'état
en quelques mots qu'elle est qu'elle est
ce qu'elle est sa philosophie
bon alors après le brillant exposé de
stéphane minson sur la loi 1905 j'ai
fait plus grand chose à ajouter tout a
été dit de manière assez claire et et
constellation de l'église et de l'état
mais cette loi de séparation de l'église
et de l'état 1905
l'idée comme à la base mais plusieurs
mais il y avait une des idées c'était
une idée de souveraineté aussi c'est à
dire d'assurer la séparation en assurant
la séparation entre l'église et l'état
s'assurer que l'église où les églises
les religions n'allait pas intervenir
aussi donc une espèce de l'effet de
retour dans les affaires de dans les
affaires de l'état
l'autre l'autre grande idée de cette loi
louis de séparation c'était d'assurer
aussi la liberté religieuse une la
neutralité de l'état
c'est la non intervention de l'état dans
les religions le fait de ne pas
privilégier une religion par rapport à
une autre
et d'assurer en retour une liberté
religieuse la plus complète aux
différents aux différents citoyens
et d'ailleurs cette loi de 1905 ne
traitez aucunement des caisses de la
question des port des signes religieux à
cette question est devenue plus tard
notamment à partir des années 2000 mais
voilà ça c'est la philosophie de base en
fait vraiment neutralité de l'état
liberté religieuse et non intervention
des religions dans les affaires de
l'état dans cette loi n'est pas remise
en cause mais il ya des ya des petites
modifications sa leçon et qui brille pas
par les petites modifications techniques
qui sont intégrés son esprit change
radicalement de là à dire le contraire
c'est pas vers une langue n'est pas on
va vers une laïcité du soupçon
c'est sûrement là il y en a qui disent
voilà c'est juste un toilettage bon pour
exposer brièvement les deux thèses c'est
juste un petit toilettage technique de
la loi de 1905 et d'autres qui comme
vous dise maintenant on passe à une
autre laïcité qui est une laïcité chucho
du laïcité de contrôle mais les deux les
deux affirmations sont vraies
c'est un toilettage technique et j'en ai
donné quelques exemples assez technique
immobile les statuts juridiques mais ce
toilettage le contrôle par le préfet
voilà les associations que dans cette
voie les préfets obtiennent un des
pouvoirs de police administrative sur
les cultes qui n'ont jamais eu et qui
ont un côté un peu anachronique
parce qu'on est revenu à l'époque du
concordat sur ce point quasiment donc
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup de mesures
techniques mais c'est des mesures
techniques qui change fondamentalement
l'esprit la laïcité française qu'on le
veuille ou non
en posant un a priori de soupçon par
rapport au citoyen croyant qu'ils sont
considérés comme des gens dont il va
falloir assurer de manière un peu serré
la fiabilité républicaine et donc c'est
pour ça que je dis que moi je suis
inquiet du climat que va engendrer cette
loi parce que je crois qu'il faut avoir
tout ce qui a été dit jusqu'à maintenant
était très intéressant sur la 1905
moi je dis rajouterai leçon processus
d'acceptation voilà faut se rappeler que
ces débats ont d'abord commencé par
scinder gravement la société française
et même par envoyer à l'étranger
1 certains citoyens français qui étaient
les religieux les moines et les moniales
ont été expulsés et son parti en
belgique en angleterre on l'aura mûri
bien vouloir quitter le territoire d'eux
mêmes ils n'y étaient pas tenu puisqu'il
était à l'étranger
ils sont rentrés se battre en 14 ils
sont rentrés se battre pour leur pays et
ils sont morts comme tous les français
dans les tranchées et cet épisode de la
guerre 14 a beaucoup joué parce que on a
à ce moment là recéler une cohésion
nationale et on a dépassé pour de bon le
côté guerrier de ces séparations mais
moi je voudrais pas qu'on perde la
mémoire de tout ça et je ne voudrais pas
que l'on réintroduisent de manière
anachronique et finalement dangereuse
une ambiance de soupçon
alors en france les croyants sont de
bons citoyens
ils sont fiers d'être engagée sur tous
les terrains de la solidarité
d'éducation comme tout le monde qu'on
leur foute la paix alors on peut avoir
peut-être une vision un peu positive
j'ai le jeu vous demande à tous
peut-être deux
nos opinions là dessus est ce que en
effet comme l'expliqué stéphane minson
on est obligé dans la loi de viser
toutes les religions mais peut-être que
dans la pratique le contrôle par exemple
d'association cultuelle catholique ne se
fera pas forcément de la même façon que
le contrôle d'association cultuelle
d'une autre religion et je pense à
l'islam est ce qu'on peut imaginer ça
stéphane écoutez donc dans la pratique
il ya déjà pas mal de comment dirais-je
de d'écart entre eux ce que dit la
lettre de la loi et la réalité des
choses et notamment ces pratiques sont
parfois encouragé sont parfois validé
mais même encouragé par la jurisprudence
par la jurisprudence administrative
notamment du conseil d'état qui depuis
2011 a rendu toute une série de
décisions qui montrent une comment
dirais-je une un regard extrêmement
extrêmement compréhensif extrêmement
libérale sur les rapports entre entre
l'état entre l'état et les religions
notamment sur la question des aides des
aides pécuniaires vincent courant de
parler de la loi de 1905 à l'instant
l'article premier de valeur
constitutionnelle garantit une proclame
la liberté de conscience et en cela
d'ailleurs il n'a rien de nouveau
puisque c'était déjà le cas en 1789
alors que l'article de lui qui est
relatif à la séparation
un hack une simple valeur législative et
il ya de nombreux textes et de
nombreuses pratiques qui se chauffent
s'arrange si vous voulez avec cette
question de la séparation donc je suis
assez convaincu que mal sur la question
de la liberté d'association là le
conseil constitutionnel aura peut-être à
effectuer a effectué quelques censure
mais je suis assez convaincu que au delà
de ce que dit le père valentin et je
l'entends et j'entends aussi ça sinon
son découragement du moins sa forme
d'agacement
mais j'entends aussi qu'il faut que la
puissance publique réagissent à l'égard
de ce qui peut se passer du côté des
associations
islamique dont on voit que elles ne sont
pas dans l'état actuel du droit
elle ne présente pas suffisamment de
garanties au regard notamment des
financements étrangers au regard de
l'infiltration de ce que de certains
états au sein de ces associations je
pense par exemple à la turquie et au
système des imams qui sont détachés qui
sont des fonctionnaires de l'état turc
qui sont détachés dans les diverses
associations
donc il faut que la puissance publique
réagissent d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est aussi dans le même temps une
attaque politique
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça parce
que oui on comprend que vous soyez une
victime collatérale en fait la religion
catholique soit une victime collatérale
mais est ce que dans ce cas là il ne
fallait rien faire
pas du tout pas du tout moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit le beaucoup des intentions et des
points précis qui sont dans cette loi me
semble comme citoyen et comme évêque
nécessaire contre la polygamie contre
les imams détaché comme ça a été dit
beaucoup de choses effectivement qui
sont dans cette loi relève de sujets sur
lesquels il fallait que l'état réagit je
suis d'accord bon mais la question c'est
comment la question c'est comment on
parlait à l'instant des pouvoirs
administratifs de police transmis au
préfet bon les recours nos capacités
pour faire appel aux juges eux qui est
au fond le seul arbitre objectifs de la
vie ensemble dans notre pays sont très
floues dans cette loi on n'a pas encore
parlé du contrat républicain l'article
si ce n'est de voter mais la façon dont
on tombera contesté le fait que nous
soyons mis en doute notre application du
contenu du contrat républicain et très
imprécise dans cette loi c'est toi le
contrat républicain bien nommé désormais
une association cultuelle encore une
fois on sait pas pourquoi les autres
citoyens eux ne sont ne sont pas
soupçonnés mais une association
cultuelle qui reçoit des subventions
publiques pour son travail d'intérêt
général
par exemple les activités caritatives il
devra signer avec l'état un contrat
d'engagement républicain voilà pourquoi
nous
je ne sais pas pourquoi que nous je ne
sais pas mais on a déjà parlé ce point
le principe est évidemment louable
bon sauf que ce contrat est basé sur des
grandes valeurs dont la définition
juridique est très flou qui vont donc
évidemment ouvrir lieu à contentieux par
exemple ce contrat précise que les
associations concernées ne doivent pas
aller contre l'ordre public
bon nous avons dit lors des auditions
mieux vaudrait parler de sécurité
publique parce que l'ordre public c'est
quoi
quand le secours catholique à calais va
installer des douches pour les gens qui
sont dans la dans la forêt il va contre
l'ordre public
la fraternité exigent parfois d'aller
contre l'ordre public ou pour parler en
termes du nouveau monde la fraternité et
disruptive bon donc évidemment qu'il y
aurait à la force injuste de la loi
évidemment qu'il y aura des moments où
l'autorité administrative contestera
certains positionnements avec l'ordre
public mais c'est avec des concepts très
flou quelles seront nos recours comment
pourrons-nous en appeler aux juges
et bien sûr tous ces points nous n'avons
pas de garanties donc donc je suis
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
mais je considère qu'aujourd'hui cette
loi introduit un arbitraire jean-charles
égard il ya eu alors une partie du texte
qui était qui était déjà déjà voté il ya
eu le débat sur le port du voile
notamment à la droite aurait voulu
qu'elle soit interdite pour les pour les
petites filles totalement ces horreurs
berger portait aussi un amendement là
dessus vous regretter qu'on n'ait pas
été plus loin là dessus sur ce sujet
bien sûr laurent berger montré beaucoup
de courage et de et c'est vraiment du
courage parce que c'est un débat que peu
de gens acceptent de auquel peu de gens
acceptent de participer si ce n'est pas
nous en donnons acariens faire maintes
fois c'est effectivement mais je dis je
le déplore enfin c'est un exemple on
enjoint aux besoins le thème de
discussion de début d'émission avec ce
qui se passe à trappes
genève n'est pas normal qu'on voit des
petites filles avec des voiles
je vais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
cette façon de voir la femme est de voir
l'humanité c'est pas l'humanité telle
que je la conçois est telle que j'ai
envie de la vivre en france facilitée
tu es clear parce que c'est pas
forcément un emblème religieux un signe
religieux
d'ailleurs mais qu'est ce que dit en
tout cas l'autorité musique c'est ce que
disent les autorités spécialisées mais
que ça douala directement les questions
religieuses
je ne sais plus quel abruti s'est
offusqué en 10 ans on parle du port du
voile chez les musulmans parlons du
voile de la mariée dans le mariage
catholique parlons de parlons de du
voile pendant les communions et faire
enfin tout ça a été une espèce de glng à
l'école c'est scandaleux
et encore une fois il faut lui il faut
non pas sévir même il faut dire à ces
gens taisez-vous enfin je veux dire
arrêtez de 2,2 de polluer le débat que
des trucs tellement stupide enfin ça n'a
plus aucun sens considère qu'elle est
votre position justement sur deux sur
cette question de la discrétion un peu
religieuse dans l'espace public est ce
qu est ce que il faut accepter de
nouveaux fonds de garder sa religion si
on est religieux c1 et croyant pour la
sphère privée alors c'est un débat qui
est inscrit dans le débat sur la laïcité
depuis les origines
voilà puisque vous savez que en 1905 il
ya eu deux courants laïcs qui se sont
affrontés celui d'emile combes et celui
d'aristide briand et parmi les éléments
de d'affrontements dans ce dont ces deux
philosophies de la laïcité
il y avait la question de savoir si
c'était l'état qui doit être laïque ou
citer la société qui devait take
l'espace public
1905 donc aristide briand a consacré une
approche de la laïcité comme
concernant l'état donc pas la société
donc dans la société dans l'espace
public
il est normal que les croyants puissent
participer à la vie commune en étant ce
qu'ils sont avec leur identité et vous
même
absolument voyez et moi j'ai l'air moi
j'ai la prétention de penser que les
croyants avec ce qu'ils sont sont un
plus pour le vivre ensemble et pas 1 -
sont un apport de par ce qu'ils ont
envie de mettre au service de tous et
que et et non pas je dirais d'abord un
problème pour la société
et moi je tiens ce qu'on préserve cette
distinction que l'état soit strictement
laïque c'est une nécessité est
aujourd'hui sans aucune ambiguïté les
évêques catholiques qui tiennent
absolument que la société française se
neutralisent me semblerait un
appauvrissement l'instant stephane sur
cette distinction entre l'état et la
société laïque
enfin il ya une complexité qui enfin qui
implique une subtilité qui est ici très
enfin à une dose extrêmement forte et
c'est toujours très compliqué à
expliquer mais moi je pense que cette
distinction entre sphère étatique et et
société civile
elle n'est pas elle n'est pas ce trail
ne correspond pas strictement à la
teneur des débats qui ont eu lieu au
moment de l'adoption de la loi de 1905
moi je parlerais plutôt de communauté
politique qui doit être laïque et
d'autres parts de sociétés civiles qui
elle est absolument sans contrainte
absolument libre il y a au sein même en
dehors même de la sphère étatique une
communauté politique à laquelle la
laïcité demande parfois un certain
détachement de ses appartenances
particulière et notamment religieuses et
et cette communauté politique
c'est en en mettant parfois de côté ses
appartenances particulière qui lui est
en théorie au moins en pratique c'est
autre chose mais en théorie au moins
plus facile de débattre d' accepter un
certain nombre de débats critiques
d'essayer de faire naître une forme de
vérité de la délibération cette
délibération elle n'est parfois pas
possible
ce que chacun reste sur ses
appartenances particulière du côté de ce
que j'appellerais la société civile la
sphère civile
la wii évidemment chacun et fort
heureusement et la laïcité c'est aussi
la garantie de cette liberté chacun est
libre donc les choses sont souvent
beaucoup plus subtil et c'est à la marge
que cette difficulté se joue je pense à
la question par exemple de la faire daby
loup où on s'était posé cette question
là baby loup c'est ni l'état ni la
société civile ou bien à la question de
la dissimulation du visage dans l'espace
public
il y a des marges qui sont extrêmement
délicates à saisir à la fois pour le
droit et pour pour le discours politique
philosophique juridique etc mais aussi
qu'ils sont en pratique très compliqué à
expliquer babilou c'était la crèche de
chanteloup-les-vignes justement la
question du port du voile équipe
interdite dans les établissements
scolaires du secondaire
le port du voile est permis à
l'université n'a toujours pas de logique
dans cette permission à partir d'un
certain âge au fond la logique la
logique c'est de ces de dire qu'un
enfant est temps qu'il est mineur il n'a
pas encore comment dire les critiques
suffisamment formés pour pour déterminer
en fait quels sont ses choix
quand son choix confessionnel qu'il
voudra faire à l'université il est
majeur et c'est un usager du service
public majeur et qui est qui qui est
donc libre de ses choix
c'est pas que c'est pas du tout la même
chose et c'est pour ça que
l'interdiction des signes religieux
ostentatoires à l'école est souvent
rapproché la question de la laïcité en
réalité c'est vraiment plus une question
d'éducation
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que même a dit la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
lorsque elle a validé le régime français
d'interdiction des signes ostentatoires
aller à l'école et donc voilà c'est
comme exactement pour la faire belle
affaire babilou pardon où là aussi la
cour de justice de l'union européenne a
dû se positionner sur cette question là
est-ce que c'est pas une atteint
à la liberté religieuse est bien là dit
elle a dit que oui clair c'est
clairement c'est une atteinte à la
liberté religieuse mais qui est justifié
ici lorsque c'est prévue dans leur
règlement intérieur lorsque c'est
nécessaire parce que l'employé va se
présenter à des clients et des
nécessités du service etc font qu' il ne
faut pas qu'ils port de signes
ostentatoires et bien c'est tout à fait
justifiée mais là il me semble qu'on est
dans des dents des dans un débat qui est
qui n'est pas exactement celui de la
laïcité qui est plus celui de la de la
liberté religieuse dans la sphère dans
la sphère civile mais mais bon voilà
oui je crois que plus on dépasse le côté
religieux c'est à dire fait surtout la
vision qu'on a de la femme c'est ce qui
justifie ce qui est rare est absolument
primordial c'est le débat est là parce
que moi je me contrefous que qu'on
puisse avoir un signe religieux
distinctif discret plus ou moins
discrets mais là c'est pas c'est pas
distinctif et disney ni discret et enfin
j'ai donc et tout le dis c'est pas les
dignitaires musulmans le dit ce n'est
pas une obligation religieuse donc c'est
juste une conception de la femme qui
n'est pas la mienne et paris celle que
je suis juste him on doit avoir en
l'origine république comme ami voilà où
nous en sommes voilà j'ai repensé que ce
qu'il dit je crois que c'est le cardinal
parolin on peut douter que ces premiers
ministres et conseillers liste upa
abonnés du pape qui dit voilà cette loi
risque de mettre en discussion les
équilibristes ocré tout au long du
siècle depuis 1905 pense que vous
partagez alors on peut se demander de
quoi il se mêle éventuellement à cette
ville nous écoutent peuvent durer de
quoi il serait là il faut savoir parce
que ça rajoute encore à la crise
est-elle écartée ni les italiens va bien
il est surtout il a la citoyenneté du
vatican aux pieds les poings ministre
vatican il faut savoir que la laïcité ça
rajoute encore à la complexité du débat
à la française elle a une dimension
internationale
parce que oui après particulier
l'adaptation du régime de 1905 aux
églises
église catholique a fait l'objet d'un
traité international
c'est le statut de cet accord entre le
saint siège et la république française
est donc aujourd'hui saint siège
tout en n'étant pas du tout dans une
logique a priori de méfiance mais
regarde d'assez près ce qui se passe en
france parce que nous sommes
internationalement engagées par ce
traité qui dans les années 20 en
définissant les associations doivent
diocésaine a été un traité diplomatique
pas simplement une loi interne à la
france mais un traité diplomatique
puisque ça fait partie des absurdités
que vous mentionnez tout à l'heure et
qui ont été ressortis pendant le débat
parlementaire les évêques sont nommés
par le pape
et ça fait juste deux mille ans que ça
dure ou à peu près et donc certains
parlementaires ne sont demandés s'il n'y
avait pas là une ingérence étrangère
douteuses dans la vie de notre pays
mais oui sujet que louis xiv se posait
déjà à son époque il faut un des motifs
napoléon à des motifs de découragement
du moment actuel pour nous c'est que
c'est le grand n'importe quoi auquel on
assiste
vous l'avez évoqué je rajoute un élément
on se demande si bientôt un prêtre
soupçonné tous complotistes nous les
catholiques juste parce qu'on prend la
résurrection s'ils voulaient me demande
heureusement nous ça va s'arrêter quoi
veulent juste bon alors peut-être si on
va au delà des débats techniques qui
sont importants parce qu'on voit très
bien quand vous les traitez combien ils
peuvent changer la philosophie de la loi
mais question philosophique c'est la
phrase de gérald darmanin la loi de la
république doit être plus forte que
celle des dieux vous en pensez quoi
mais alors là aussi sous les jeux
j'oscille entre la consternation et le
découragement
parce que évidemment c'est pas vrai
évidemment que c'est pas vrai évidemment
qu'en 42
on est content face au régime de vichy
concernant les juifs que des gens aient
suivi leur conscience plutôt qu'à loi de
l'état évidemment qu'on est con et
heureux pour l'humanité toute entière
que dans les années 90 en afrique d'ici
à nelson mandela est suivi sa conscience
plutôt que l'autorité de l'état la loi
de dieu c'est pas une réalité qui tombe
de jeunes c'est qu'elle trône céleste
pause c'est ce qu'entend ma conscience
c'est ce qu'entend ma conscience et on
ne peut pas même si j'ai bien compris
que c'était un slogan rapide mais on ne
peut pas anéantir de manière aussi
cinglante la nécessité évidente de
respecter le jugement de conscience dans
une sphère qui n'est pas celle de la vie
citoyenne
moi ma foi catholique me fait obligation
d'être un bon citoyen et me demande même
de prier pour les dirigeants politiques
de mon pays donc j'ai aucun problème
avec le sujet et pour autant jamais je
ne signerai une telle phrase parce que
évidemment qu'on ne peut pas mettre la
loi de l'état dans une vision aussi
totalitaires faire l'avocate darmanin
pour une fois mais on voit bien le sud à
qui était mon nom mais on est toujours
dans cette ambiguïté très clairement par
dessiner
on est toujours sur le même sujet mais
dans ces moments-là problème
réglons les problèmes une certaine
tension de les ongles aux élections
d'icloud eric grasset de djihad
vous comprenez donc le problème c'est
sans doute ça mais les conneries réunies
en face mais comme disent les juristes
voilà on peut pas tout traiter un
problème particulier il faut traiter des
problèmes de manière générale voilà on a
fait à peu près le le tour sur des
reproches que vous faites à cette loi on
va voi va sans doute rate adopté on
verra quelle sera votre attitude ensuite
à papa sera l'attitude républicaine ça
va sans dire c'est à dire que d'abord
nous allons aux commissions
parlementaires qui nous invite nous
discutons nous débattons et puis ensuite
le cas échéant nous ferons appel au
conseil constitutionnel nous ferons
appel à tous les recours que nous donne
la loi républicaine alors on va passer à
un autre sujet me nous reste qu'à peine
trois minutes et donc pas assez pour en
débattre
c'est un sujet de justice c'est vrai que
voilà c'est l'actualité était marquée
par plusieurs affaires
cest dernièrement on je voudrais juste
vous interroger sur un point qui me
paraît intéressant philosophiquement et
peut-être juridiquement on parle
beaucoup de lui évidemment la plupart de
ces affaires sont prescrites et on parle
beaucoup d'une suppression de la
prescription
dans ce genre d'affaires et je disais ce
que disait un avocat et c'est une part
est intéressant il disait la morale ne
se prescrit pas mais le droit doit être
prescrit qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette phrase à une
question qu'elle a posées au jury
spécial je ne donnerai pas de nom
semblable ou 0 jean charles non non moi
je suis assez d'accord
l'avocat que je ne connais pas je ne
sais pas tu dis de paris voilà non mais
ensuite si on veut débattre pourquoi les
affaires de vieux pourquoi des affaires
d'inceste et pas telle autre pourquoi je
ne vois pas seulement le voit on voit
une raison c'est à dire que un enfant
qui a subi des violences sexuelles
pendant toute son enfance de ne peut pas
se plaindre et qui fusent et d'ailleurs
dans la loi a changé là dessus puisque
c'est à partir de sa majorité l'art
chrétien dollars et youku qu'un décalage
jusqu'à la majorité tout à fait normal
après un prescrit bilité ne me semble
folle c'était fin des pinceaux sur la
prescription justement des crimes qu
est-ce qu il quel est votre point de vue
la situation pour les les incestes n'a
cessé d'évoluer ou c'est que cette
prescription elle elle compte à compte
et elle part à partir de la majorité de
la personne et elle vaut pour 30 ans
donc jusqu'à l'âge de 48 ans il est
encore possible de d'actionner les les
procédures mais la prescription c'est
aussi un mécanisme alors qu il
différencie de de la morale le droit
n'est pas la morale même si la morale
influent bien évidemment sur le droit
mais il ya pour le coup ici aussi des
questions techniques
c'est à dire que reprendre une affaire
des décennies après la commission des
infractions qui peuvent être reprochées
c'est extrêmement compliqué et ça risque
parfois de conduire vers des verts des
erreurs judiciaires qui sont qui peuvent
être parfois irrattrapable donc faire
parler des témoins des décennies après
faire parler des preuves même avec des
moyens techniques qui sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement extrêmement performant c'est
tout de suite
extrêmement compliqué au regard de
l'impératif de justice dans le droit
canonique il ya une prescription
le droit canonique a beaucoup évolué
récemment sur ces questions parce que
chacun sait que l'église catholique a
été très très confronté pas au coin de
l'inceste évidemment aux problèmes
d'abus sur mineurs est aujourd'hui en
droit canonique il est prévu que sur
décision du pape la prescription puisse
être levé et ça a été le cas dans
plusieurs affaires en france deux
prêtres qui ne pouvait plus être jugé
pour le par les tribunaux mais qui ont
pu être dit j d'un point de vue
canonique parce que le saint siège a
considéré que vis-à-vis des victimes il
fallait lever la prescription et
m'écoutent et c'est sur ces paroles
convainc qu'on va se quitter merci
infiniment ont cédé à bruno valentin
d'avoir participé à cette émission vers
si beaucoup jean charles lajoie dit
merci beaucoup
vincent couronne et stéphane manceau et
à très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
paf
[Musique]